who are you looking for I'm looking for
it I can help her what's going on
uniform one night
yeah I can help her what's going on yeah
no I know what happened I know the
people they're involved so
go again
you know thank you
what's your name
I'm not gonna tell you my name I don't
give a
because I know what happened I needed me
to know figure it out what happened
if you don't have me you don't know what
happened I just know that some guy come
here yeah some guy I don't know what
happened right I don't know what
happened he just got you're gonna think
about me but it's not gonna be me
because it's not proof
so so you think something's happened to
a male in this address no I know what
happened what happened tell me what
happened this city is mine the city is
yours is it yeah
can you get in the van please
not to man handle you but we need you to
get in the van